ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález 60 años han
pasado desde el inicio del embargo
económico impuesto por estados unidos a
la isla de cuba una vez triunfo la
revolución liderada por fidel castro-
que llevó a ese país del caribe a dar un
giro hacia un gobierno comunista
para eeuu el embargo fue la respuesta de
la casa blanca para buscar
compensaciones después de las
nacionalizaciones y expropiaciones de
empresas que eran propiedad de
estadounidenses que en su mayoría pues
tenían allí grandes extensiones de
tierras refinerías y haciendas muchas de
ellas dedicadas al negocio azucarero
veamos una cronología rápida muy rápida
para ponernos en contexto en 1960
comenzaron las primeras reacciones por
parte de eeuu al suspender las
exportaciones a cuba sólo quedaron
exentos los medicamentos y los alimentos
pero en 1962 en el gobierno de john
f.kennedy implementan un paquete de
restricciones y sanciones a cuba y
comienza formalmente digámoslo así el
embargo económico a cuba esto se mantuvo
hasta 1992 y 1996 cuando el gobierno del
presidente clinton endureció las
restricciones y prácticamente prohibió
hacer todo tipo de negocios con la isla
y también limitó el acceso de la misma a
dólares en el mercado extranjero una ley
conocida como la ley helms burton
en 1999 finalmente washington impuso
restricciones a sus exportaciones de
medicamentos hacia la isla hasta ahora
como lo habíamos dicho estaban exentos
de todas estas restricciones y
limitaciones pero entre el 2009 y el
2017 durante el gobierno del presidente
barack obama hubo un cambio en la
política hacia cuba y son restablecidas
las relaciones diplomáticas comerciales
económicas y también son permitidos los
viajes de los estadounidenses hacia esta
isla del caribe
en 2019 el gobierno de donald trump
restituyó todas las sanciones y
restricciones y revirtió todo lo que
había impuesto el gobierno del
presidente barack obama
bueno eso desde la perspectiva de eeuu y
viendo un poco paso a paso a lo largo de
las décadas las diferentes coyunturas y
los diferentes momentos en los que el
embargo se recrudeció o fue revertido
como lo decíamos con el presidente
barack obama pero que hay de la mirada
cubana la puesta en marcha y la
ampliación del embargo en diferentes
momentos a lo largo de estos 60 años ha
tenido diferentes efectos en la isla
según el ministerio de economía y
planificación
el mep cuba ha dejado de recibir entre
148 mil y 150 mil millones de dólares en
ingresos por el embargo debido a estas
restricciones el país tiene un limitado
acceso a tecnología moderna determinados
bienes y servicios uno de los sectores
más afectados es el de la salud debido a
que hay restricciones para adquirir
medicamentos también equipos y
tecnología médica extranjera y moderna y
también a productos que cuenten con
patentes de eeuu
que tanto ha pasado entonces en la
política exterior de eeuu para sostener
este embargo a lo largo de estas seis
décadas que ha significado para cuba
este embargo es una política y un
discurso que ya es obsoleto si lo vemos
desde la coyuntura actual hoy en el
debate de france 24 60 años del inicio
del embargo económico de estados unidos
a cuba para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a maría fernanda barreto
escritora y analista especializada en
temas de geopolítica latinoamericana
también es feminista y defensora de los
derechos humanos
ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
caracas en la capital venezolana y desde
la ciudad de miami se conecta sebastián
arcos cazabonne él es director asociado
del instituto de investigaciones cubanas
de la universidad internacional de la
florida en la ciudad de miami como ya lo
decía en el sur de los eeuu france24
intentó contactar a representantes del
gobierno y de la sociedad cubana y
estadounidense para poder hablar sobre
este tema y no fue posible concretar una
participación de alguna de estas partes
en el programa pero eso sí ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 bajo ese arroba santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal el numeral es la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos los comentarios y las
preguntas y muy bien pues ya tenemos
algo de contexto tenemos a nuestros
invitados comienzo con maria fernanda en
la ciudad de caracas
preguntándole por estos 60 años de
embargo qué tan efectivo ha sido desde
el punto de vista de eeuu qué tan
efectivo ha sido y qué tanto ha afectado
a cuba y al gobierno de los castro
hola bueno en primer lugar siempre un
gusto estar aquí en france 24 y en tu
programa un saludo para quienes nos
escuchan y a mi contertulio por supuesto
mira en realidad este bloqueo criminal
que tiene ya seis décadas aplicándose
contra cuba no ha arrojado ningún
resultado positivo desde ningún punto de
vista ni ha tenido ningún ninguna
implicación positiva por supuesto para
el pueblo cubano quien ha traído
simplemente sufrimientos restricciones
la imposibilidad de desarrollarse
económicamente de acuerdo a sus
potencialidades y mucho sufrimiento para
los niños niñas hombres y mujeres que
habitan la isla de cuba pero tampoco ha
surtido ningún efecto desde el punto de
vista político ni militar desde el cual
fue planteado porque hay que decir que
este bloqueo como todos los bloqueos son
medidas de guerra acciones de guerra que
ya son arcaicas y no
ni siquiera para los propios eeuu y sus
intereses políticos militares sobre cuba
ningún avance positivo porque su
planteamiento inicial fue que haciendo
sufrir al pueblo cubano y voy a lograr
que ese pueblo cubano se aliará con los
de eeuu para derrotar la revolución
cubana y 60 años después eso no ha
sucedido y no está cerca de suceder así
que este bloqueo no ha generado más
ganancia que la que se ha generado por
vía de los robos de expropiaciones a los
que si directa e indirectamente ha
conducido ya los que pretende conducir
con la activación del capítulo 3 de la
ley helms burton que el show de
recientemente delante de sebastian en la
ciudad de miami en el sur de eeuu en la
misma pregunta para el inicio del debate
60 años de embargo por parte de eeuu que
tan efectivo ha sido para la política
exterior de eeuu estas medidas y que
tanto ha afectado a cuba
veamos
la función original del embargo era un
castigo al régimen cubano por la
confiscación de más de mil millones de
dólares del año 60 que mucho más hoy en
día
en propiedades norteamericanas en la
isla sin compensación
y
como segundo lugar
ocasionar un cambio de actitud del
régimen cubano con respecto a esas
propiedades norteamericanas y a la
relación por supuesto bilateral con eeuu
y en tercer lugar
limitar el daño que podría hacer una
revolución
comunista en el medio del hemisferio
occidental o sea disminuir la cantidad
de recursos a los que tenía acceso un
régimen que ya se veía claramente que
estaba inclinado hacia la unión
soviética si miramos estos tres estas
tres razones
vemos que la primera no dio resultados
las propiedades no han sido restauradas
por supuesto no se ha pagado
compensación por las propiedades robadas
en segundo lugar el régimen cubano no ha
cambiado de actitud en este sentido las
sanciones económicas no han logrado que
el régimen cambie su actitud vis-à-vis
los eeuu en tercer lugar se puede
considerar que fue más o menos efectivo
al limitar el número de recursos que
tenían
y me cubano para fomentar ese tipo de
revoluciones el resto de américa latina
y el relativo porque ha tenido defecto
por ejemplo venezuela yo creo que es el
mejor de ellos de como el régimen cubano
se ha podido expandirse a otros países
de américa latina pero imaginemos las
capacidades que hubiera tenido de no ser
precisamente por las limitaciones
presentadas por el embargo hay que notar
sí que hay una diferencia entre embargo
y bloqueo por supuesto
la siguiente pregunta
sebastián y va a justamente hacer esa
esa aclaración sobre los los términos
porque desde eeuu se habla de un embargo
pero desde la habana se habla de un
bloqueo maria fernanda porque el
gobierno cubano mantiene este discurso y
lo llama bloqueo para hacer una
aclaración en cuanto a los términos y
claramente pues para tener las dos
perspectivas de la habana y washington
bueno porque tanto desde el punto de
vista semántico como desde el punto de
vista político hay un uso digamos
siempre relativo de ambos términos tanto
embargo como bloqueo
el embargo no debería en términos
jurídicos ser de aplicación
extraterritorial y mucho menos a
terceros como lo está haciendo
actualmente el bloqueo a cuba y el
bloqueo suele utilizarse en la
definición más arcaica de las viejas
teorías de la guerra en las que se
limitaba un bloqueo naval lo que vive en
este momento cuba es un bloqueo sobre
todo cuando lo vemos desde el punto de
vista de las nuevas teorías de la guerra
cuando hablamos de una guerra
multidimensional porque el agua no
solamente se la están aplicando
restricciones comerciales que son las
que limitan la definición de embargo
sino que además se les está bloqueando
por ejemplo comunicacionalmente hay una
gran cantidad de aplicaciones que no
funcionan en la isla directamente hay
host que se niegan a alojar lugares
virtuales de
de cuba y por ejemplo también se le
impide la llegada de buques hasta los
puertos cubanos o se aplican medidas
digamos indirectas que hacen que buques
que lleven alimentos o medicinas a cuba
luego entonces no sean admitidos en
puertos estadounidenses entonces más
allá de ese decreto que firmó kennedy el
3 de febrero de 62 y como bien apuntar
usted en el resumen luego se editaron
nuevas leyes como la ley helms burton en
este caso que endurecieron esas medidas
y avanzaron de embargo a bloqueo y esa
es la realidad tenemos un bloqueo que es
parte de una guerra multidimensional
contra cuba y como como parte de la
guerra multinacional pues tiene muchos
aspectos que van más allá de lo
estrictamente comercial que es a lo que
nos refiere la palabra embargo pero
además así quería decir que el
contertulio señaló que este decreto se
se basa en un contexto que ya no existe
es el contexto de la guerra fría que ya
no existe hay un argumento de su
arcaísmo y peor acción maria firmando
este decreto se emitió se basaron en un
d en una ley también emitida en el
contexto de la primera guerra mundial
contra los enemigos de los estados
analizar el contexto el contexto actual
y las relaciones internacionales en el
contexto actual y cómo está cuba porque
además en cuba hubo un cambio no llegó
otro presidente y a lo largo de esta
historia en eeuu han pasado múltiples
gobiernos y pues las coyunturas
internacionales han cambiado ya vale la
pena analizar si este discurso es
completamente obsoleto tanto en
washington como en la habana le hago la
pregunta entonces a sebastián hablamos
aquí de un embargo o de un bloqueo de
acuerdo a mis notas en un bloqueo
consiste en impedir que haya una para
una demarcación puntual se pueda
comerciar con el resto del mundo pero
cuba puede comerciar con el resto de
países tiene comercio con venezuela como
ya lo hemos visto con nicaragua con
rusia con china
y tiene asistencia por parte de algunos
organismos internacionales entonces a la
luz de la teoría y el término de bloqueo
no sería aplicado acá porque hay
simplemente una restricción a nivel
económico comercial y financiero lo que
en la práctica sería entonces un embargo
sebastián como lo que usted
está claro en términos de término de
terminología y del concepto el bloqueo
es un concepto militar cuba estuvo
bloqueada por estados unidos en octubre
del año 62 durante la crisis de los
misiles cuando buques de la marina
norteamericana impedían la entrada o
salida de buques de puertos cubanos eso
es un bloqueo es una connotación militar
es fundamental hay una diferencia
importantísima entre eso y un embargo el
régimen sudafricano de apartheid estuvo
bajo un casi bloqueo que no llegó a ser
militar pero donde se aplicaron
sanciones que iban más allá de la
economía como por ejemplo no invitarlos
a los deportistas a funciones deportivas
fuera del mundo o culturales etcétera
eso sería una cosa quizás más cercana a
un bloqueo pero tampoco llegaría de esa
dimensión efectivamente como ha dicho
usted el gobierno como lo puede
comerciar con la inmensa mayoría de los
el mundo esto es un embargo comercial
bilateral con los estados unidos de
hecho los principales inversionistas
occidentales en cuba hoy en día son
españa canadá japón
francia italia todos aliados de los
estados seguidos y sin embargo comercian
libremente sin ningún tipo de
interferencia con el régimen cubano la
ley helms burton tiene una aplicación
muy puntual sobre el uso de propiedades
que fueron confiscadas a ciudadanos
norteamericanos y no se puede aplicar
más allá de esa función de manera que
para reiterar se trata de un embargo
comercial
bilateral que además tiene numerosos
agujeros para citar el más importante
por ejemplo eeuu le vende a cuba
alimentos y medicinas desde el año
1999 su cronología por cierto tiene ese
error
desde el año 99 cv vall compras en eeuu
grandes cantidades de medicamentos y de
medicinas de hecho todo el pollo que se
comercializa en cuba internamente
actualmente viene de los eeuu y mucha
medicina que se comercializa también
viene de los eeuu de manera que el
bloqueo no es tal es un embargo y que no
se aplica fundamentalmente a medidas
financieras
maria fernanda su opinión
completamente en desacuerdo primero
porque conozco el bloqueo desde su
realidad conozco cuba y vivo en otro
país bloqueado que es la república
bolivariana de venezuela conozco las
consecuencias directas en la población y
lo conozco como parte de la población a
mí personalmente se me ha complicado en
la adquisición de medicinas en el
exterior medicinas que sólo se produce
en el laboratorio estadounidense
producto del bloqueo en lo personal no
soy presidenta no ocupó ningún cargo
público no estoy sancionada
personalmente en la definición de
bloqueo que cita mi contertulio que tal
como lo mencioné es una definición de
teorías de la guerra arcaicas que ya no
están vigentes las actuales teorías de
la guerra son teorías de cuarta
generación de quinta generación de
hablamos de guerras y brisas
multidimensionales donde los bloqueos
trascienden lo naval
e incluso lo estrictamente físico físico
militar digamos ya estamos hablando de
por ejemplo lo importante que es hoy día
dentro de las guerras los bloqueos
comunicacionales el terrorismo
financiero porque cuando tú dices que
cuba puede comerciar libremente con
otros países no es cierto porque las
medidas financieras contra cuba por
ejemplo implican las complicaciones con
el sistema swift que es un sistema
caracterizado por los estados unidos y
por la banca internacional de reserva
federal y toda esta esta banca que al
final está subordinada a las
definiciones del principio de la
principal economía del mundo que
relativamente continúa siendo hoy los
eeuu y lo cierto es y ahí mi contertulio
no me ha contradecido que sea embargo o
sea bloque o ambas tienen un origen
militar y su aplicación es parte de una
visión militarista de la política
nadie que esté contra las acciones
militares como medida de coacción para
ingerir en asuntos internos de otros
países puede apoyar los bloqueos porque
estaba hablando largo de externos y no
es verde internos pero ni no es verdad
que son medidas bilaterales entre eeuu y
cuba
porque entre las últimas más de 260
medidas que di todo electrón está la
sanción a terceros países y además todas
las empresas de esos terceros países
como las propias empresas españolas y lo
ha manifestado públicamente los
representantes de españa y la unión
europea se ven afectadas por estas
definiciones de los estados unidos que
luego sancionan a esas empresas por el
hecho de haber comercio con google y
además se niega a recibir productos que
contengan por ejemplo también
implementos o materias primas cubanos
hay una serie de acciones del verdadero
terrorismo financiero contra cuba que
más le impide el acceso a créditos
cuando se compra los eeuu
como es lo normal en el capitalismo que
impera en el mundo
de la calificación de riesgo o sea
que usted explica qué esfuerzos ha hecho
entonces el gobierno cubano para
evidenciar esto en la comunidad
internacional para dar a conocer la
situación para revertir un poco esta
está este panorama y está este embargo
impuesto por eeuu
vemos que por ejemplo en la organización
de naciones unidas siempre la votación
de éstas
[Música]
emociones para levantar el embargo por
parte de eeuu tiene un fuerte apoyo
internacional solamente eeuu israel
se mantienen en la misma postura pero la
comunidad internacional parece estar del
lado de cuba pero entonces le ha faltado
a cuba a hacer más esfuerzo le ha
faltado a cuba en recibir un verdadero
apoyo internacional como lo ve usted
perdóname que me hablas a mi verdad
fernando
mira yo creo que es evidente que el
mundo entero está pidiendo el fin de ese
tipo de acciones en el mundo contra cuba
y contra el mundo los bloqueos los
embargos y que su fe místicamente los
quieren llamar así
son arcaicos son inhumanos y son
violatorios del derecho internacional de
la carta fundacional de las naciones
unidas y migratorios de los derechos
humanos como madre como mujer
latinoamericana
no puedo decir más que el bloqueo a cuba
es un crimen contra la humanidad el hipo
y en ese sentido el propio antonio
guterres el secretario general de las
naciones unidas las propias naciones
unidas como tú mismo manifiestas
prácticamente de manera unánime
se manifiesta cada año contra el bloqueo
a cuba lo que falta
y esa hegemonía tan absoluta que tiene
la reserva federal y los estados unidos
sobre los problemas se suite sobre el
sistema bancario pues permite que
realmente se terminen de derrumbar todas
las barreras y comience
realmente un nuevo un nuevo momento en
el que las medidas coercitivas
unilaterales
dejen de ser aplicadas en el mundo
fernando por favor le pido que sea más
puntual con las respuestas tengo muchos
temas para preguntarles y muy poco
tiempo sebastián en su opinión sobre
esta postura de los países que conforman
naciones unidas ha habido votaciones por
ejemplo por citar unas 184 votos en
contra el embargo ya lo decía yo
solamente dos países estados unidos e
israel' más de 20 veces se ha votado de
esta manera esto no tiene un peso
político muy grande para eeuu a nivel
internacional
no
no hay duda de que la política
norteamericana interés sanciones a cuba
es
muy popular en las naciones unidas y no
cuenta con el apoyo de prácticamente
ninguna nación en el caso del voto
israel es un voto de solidaridad con
eeuu y no creo que se trate de mucho más
que eso porque incluso israel que es un
aliado para acercar los eeuu tiene
inversiones en cuba
compañías que operan en cuba y hacen
recordemos que los embargos son
un instrumento de las relaciones
exteriores de todos los países del mundo
desde hace mucho tiempo recordemos que
hubo un embargo contra sudáfrica hubo un
embargo contra irak durante el gobierno
de saddam 26 ahora mismo hay un embargo
comercial que incluye múltiples acciones
financieras de múltiples países
incluyendo países europeos en contra de
irán de manera que los embargos son
bastante comunes y bastante actuales en
la política internacional casi nunca
funcionan a cabalidad
porque requieren para que funcionen
traen su implementación colectiva y este
es raramente el caso como podemos ver en
el caso de irán ahora mismo china y
rúsia comercial covirán que de manera
que es una función bastante normal pero
que tiene muy poca popularidad
muy poca popularidad quiero preguntarle
a los dos sobre este tipo de media maria
fernanda ya en algunas de sus
intervenciones ha hecho que son medidas
arcaicas obsoletas como no ver a ustedes
como lo ve usted sebastián en pleno 2022
seguir con este tipo de embargos 60 años
presionando en cierta manera al gobierno
cubano y la economía de este país y eeuu
con una gran presión también a nivel
internacional
'estoy absoluto es momento de cambiar el
discurso es momento de cambiar la
estrategia por parte de los dos países
además que hemos visto luces con el
gobierno de barack obama vimos que
pueden conversar los dos países que
puede haber un acercamiento
no estén de acuerdo en la forma de
gobierno que puede haber en un país o en
el otro pero que pueda haber un
entendimiento comercial
correcto y
acabo de enumerar una serie de sanciones
a otros países que demuestran que los
embargos no son obsoletos los embargos
son un instrumento activo de las
relaciones internacionales de hecho
ahora mismo europa está considerando
sanciones contra rusia en caso de una
invasión a
ucrania lo cual demuestra la actualidad
y el uso habitual de las acciones
económicas en las relaciones
internacionales modernas ahora
eeuu ha mantenido una política de
aislamiento bilateral en el caso de cuba
hace muchos años que no se implementan
sanciones que incluía a compañías
norteamericanas de terceros países esas
sanciones eliminaron el año 74 hace ya
mucho tiempo y no sea el rey impuesto de
nuevo
eeuu claramente ha considerado en
momentos aflojar o apretar las sanciones
de acuerdo a circunstancias puntuales en
la relación bilateral de ambos países
que sigue siendo muy tensa porque la
situación fundamental en ambas naciones
no ha cambiado en los últimos 60 años
eeuu desearía que cuba fuese un país
democrático y abierto a la economía
mundial y cuba hace 60 años que es
exactamente lo contrario además es un
enemigo declarado de los eeuu y amigo
cercano de todos los enemigos que tiene
eeuu del mundo no hay razón más allá del
experimento de obama para que estados
unido cambien su política maría fernanda
muy puntual por favor su opinión bueno
en primer lugar los deseos de los eeuu
sobre cómo debemos gobernar nos en el
resto de los países no deben ser la
norma a seguir porque en este mundo
unipolar ha llegado a su fin y estamos
en la construcción de un mundo
multiplicó y pluripolar que es
verdadera garantía de paz para el mundo
realmente sinceramente 60 años de hacer
sufrir al pueblo cubano ya son más que
suficiente el bloqueo de los estados
unidos contra cuba debe cesar nadie
nadie que defienda los derechos humanos
que tenga un mínimo de amor por la
humanidad y que cree en la política con
p mayúscula
puede apoyar acciones
militares y los crímenes de guerra que
ellos conllevan contra países como en
este caso cuba como venezuela como como
siria como todos los países contra los
que los eeuu ha venido apoyando este
tipo de medidas coercitivas unilaterales
y extraterritoriales
ilegales y por supuesto violatoria de
los derechos humanos yo me los juntando
sencillamente el hecho de que las
guerras sean comunes que los embargos
sean comunes que los crímenes de guerra
sean comunes común pueden señalar el
contertulio no los hace
maria fernanda y mucho menos justos que
tanto este discurso desde la habana
desde el gobierno cubano este discurso
de mantener el embargo como un un
discurso para toda la población para
justificar el estancamiento económico
que tanto le sirve esto al gobierno
cubano para tener siempre un enemigo
externo que es el causante de todos los
problemas así lo han dicho varias veces
en cuba el gobierno y para justificar
que la economía cubana esté estancada
que no se haya podido modernizar que
esté completamente
estancada y que no pueda acceder a
a otros beneficios para los ciudadanos
cubanos que tanto es esto un discurso
político para ellos
conmigo si me
mira en realidad en primer lugar nunca
se haya negado que haya dificultades
internas de hecho recientemente vi una
entrevista al ministro malmierca donde
habla de que ciertamente hay algunas
dificultades y limitaciones internas
pero lo cierto es que cuba es una
economía pequeña cuál es su posibilidad
real de desarrollarse en el socialismo
no lo hemos podido saber no lo sabe cuba
no lo saben los eeuu porque nunca desde
el triunfo de la revolución se le ha
dado la posibilidad de desarrollar todo
su potencial según sus propios
planteamientos
soberanos son a los que tiene derecho
entonces no sabemos hasta qué punto hay
unas cifras por supuesto de daños que
han sido medidos de impactos directos en
la economía cubana muy cierto y el
sufrimiento cotidiano que causa el no
poder acceder libremente a medicinas ha
repuesto
alimentos a equipos médicos
en medio de la pandemia aún más ese
impacto cotidiano
en el pueblo cubano claro pero cuando
cuba era muy cercano a la entonces unión
soviética que recibía tantos subsidios y
tantas ayudas de la unión soviética
tampoco pudo desarrollar su economía
como supuestamente el socialismo
prometía que se iba a desarrollar y una
vez cayó la unión soviética pues se ve
la entrada a este período especial
porque la economía simplemente no da el
80 por ciento de los productos que se
consumen en cuba tienen que ser
importados porque su economía no puede
producirlo no puede abastecerse y no
puede abastecer ni garantizar cosas
básicas a sus ciudadanos hago la
pregunta a la inversa entonces sebastián
que tanto esto sirve de discurso para
eeuu para mantener un enemigo en el
caribe un punto al que lanzar críticas y
también para garantizar un voto muy
importante que es el de los exiliados
cubanos en el sur de eeuu que es un voto
importante para los republicanos
bueno en realidad el embargo le ha sido
perjudicial a la imagen de eeuu a nivel
internacional de manera que ahí no vemos
ningún argumento a favor para que eeuu
mantenga una política que
de otra manera se podría considerar
perjudicial para la diplomacia
norteamericana en cuanto al
beneficio de los votantes cubanos los
votantes cubanos cambian en algunas
elecciones únicas exclusivamente en el
estado de la florida y tienen ninguna
influencia en el resto de los 49 estados
de eeuu de manera que considera que el
voto cubano es fundamental para ganar
una elección presidencial en eeuu una
exageración gigantesca el embargo es una
pantalla de humo para el régimen cubano
para esconder su propia incompetencia la
incompetencia de un modelo
descentralizado
y marxista que lleva desde hace 60 años
y que ha exportado por cierto a
venezuela ya ha causado exactamente el
mismo resultado
de pobreza en miseria y desinversión del
país la responsabilidad es interna pero
es siempre importante buscar un enemigo
externo sobre todo
a dictaduras como la del gobierno cual
sí pero desde la óptica de eeuu
sebastián que lo que le estoy
preguntando muy puntual por favor uno
desde la óptica de los eeuu ya lo dije
no conlleva ningún beneficio particular
mantener una política de embargo la
política se mantiene porque se me queda
que es un instrumento valioso me queda
un minuto para cerrar el programa
conclusiones maría fernanda muy puntual
que va a pasar seguiremos con el embargo
más décadas por delante como lo vio
usted
conclusiones cuando quieran tenemos un
debate sobre economía socialista porque
veo que realmente hay gran interés en el
tema con respecto al bloqueo el bloqueo
debe cesar no es útil para nadie viola
los derechos humanos viola la el derecho
internacional y lo único que ocasiona es
sufrimiento al pueblo cubano y maría
fernanda añade cuba- sebastián su
conclusión por favor que me quedan pocos
segundos para terminar el programa
el embargo no cambiará a corto plazo ya
vemos que hay una administración
demócrata que tampoco ha decidido mover
el embargo y la razón fundamental es que
el régimen cubano se niega a hacer las
reformas fundamentales para que su
propio pueblo pueda vivir mejor y luego
depender de una nación de traer a sí
pues a mis invitados les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros hoy les
agradezco sus diferentes puntos de vista
para analizar este tema ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas y sigan por supuesto con la
programación de france 24
[Música]